okay let's talk about the rapidly
growing rift between former Democratic
presidential candidate Bernie Sanders
and his own supporters the same Bernie
supporters who have praised Bernie for
saying he's been saying the same thing
for forty years he's consistent he
doesn't sell out he always tells you
what you think he doesn't bow to
corporate interest he doesn't bow to
party politics all of the stuff a lot of
Bernie supporters are now saying he sold
out by saying support Biden he sold out
he's nearly 80 years old
what exactly does selling out mean for
Bernie Sanders at this point in time
what is he trying to position himself
for by selling out Bernie said yesterday
that it would be irresponsible for his
supporters not to vote for Joe Biden in
November and a ton of Bernie supporters
are absolutely furious for some reason
they're tweeting at me on Twitter I
don't know why that's going on but it is
this is all from an interview that
Bernie did with The Associated Press and
it is getting very ugly Bernie was asked
about the choice that his supporters now
have to make and Bernie Sanders said
quote do we be as active as we can in
electing Joe Biden and doing everything
we can to move Joe and his campaign in a
more progressive direction or do we
choose to sit it out and allow the most
dangerous president in modern American
history to get reelected
I believe that it's irresponsible for
anybody to say well I disagree with Joe
Biden I disagree with Joe Biden and
therefore I'm not going to be involved
Bernie says that this is it Bernie says
it's Joe Biden time he says despite
technically still being on future
primary ballots Bernie will not be
advertising he won't be running ads he
won't be spending money and that he is
all in for Joe Biden and that it would
be irresponsible for his supporters not
to be so if you are a Bernie supporter
I'm trying to figure out how you square
praising Bernie for never selling out
always speaking his mind always
for 40 years 40 years and then now it's
78 years of age bernie has become
disingenuous and a tool of the
Democratic Party if that's really what
you believe about about Bernie Sanders
right now it's very hard to imagine you
had the right assessment of him all
along I believe the simpler explanation
is Bernie just gets it
Bernie much like Noam Chomsky understand
the importance of removing Donald Trump
now another source of controversy from
the same interview with The Associated
Press is that bernie is being accused by
some of attacking his own supporters
because he sort of distanced himself
from a woman named Brianna joy Gray who
was his press secretary at one point in
time she posted on Twitter a quote with
the utmost respect for Bernie Sanders
who is an incredible human being and a
genuine inspiration
I don't endorse Joe Biden I supported
Bernie because he backed ideas like
medicare-for-all cancelling all student
debt and a wealth tax Biden supports
none of those to me this is the the in
you know just the epitome of a misguided
comment because okay Biden's not for
Medicare for all but he wants to expand
it to 60-plus which would give it to 20
million more people Trump wants to
kicked 32 million people off of health
insurance Joe Biden just put out a plan
for partial cancellation of some student
that Trump you know now is being forced
into suspending some payments because of
coronavirus but Biden's better than
Trump on that on the wealth tax okay
Biden doesn't support Warren or Bernie's
wealth tax but Biden's tax plan and
capital gains tax implant is way better
than Donald Trump so to me this is you
know missing the forest for the trees
but in any case Bernie was asked about
the comments from Brianna Joy gray and
he did a sort of Brianna who kind of
thing telling The Associated Press
simply she is my former press secretary
not on the payroll which is kind of a
funny cop-out because Bernie's campaign
confirmed no one's on the payroll like
in other words the campaign is over and
this reaction from Bernie about Brianna
is throwing a lot of people into total
disarray on Twitter some people are
saying bernie is a
hacking his supporters by saying this so
once again my goal going forward is I
don't want to split the left into
factions I want to just bring the left
together to defeat Donald Trump all of
the woke Twitter stuff is dividing the
left and it helps Trump so first of all
my hope and instinct is that the very
loud Twitter reddit online Bernie Biden
stuff is overblown and that while it's
very divisive on the Internet I'm hoping
it's not that divisive in the real world
if the primary taught us one thing it's
that the loud Bernie Wing is very loud
online but it didn't translate to that
many voters Joe Biden is ahead of Bernie
by nearly three million votes right now
and so in the same way just because the
group is louder on Twitter doesn't mean
there are necessarily that many of them
my hope is that outside of this Twitter
area there is not really that much
division among the left and it's clear
that we need to vote to remove Donald
Trump but what's going on here is simply
that a lot of people are just struggling
with it Bernie realizes Trump is an
existential threat to the world and his
handling of coronavirus has proven that
even more acutely in practice you're
either helping Trump's proto-fascist
authoritarian baby dictatorship or
you're working against it it is true
that if you don't vote you're not voting
that's not literally a vote for Trump
this idea of not voting is a vote for
Trump no it's not literally true but
we've got to be adults by staying home
because you voted Bernie and you won't
vote Biden you are furthering Trump's
proto-fascist authoritarian re-election
if you're not activating against it you
are essentially one more vote for
allowing it and I can't do that there's
no neutrality here now maybe you feel
okay about having that role because
you're an acceleration Istanbul Eve in
other four years of Trump will more
quickly destroy the system and lead to
it being rebuilt in a better sort of
framework okay that that's fine let's
just call things what they are though
Bernie is acting sensibly and normally
here if you believe Bernie has been
genuine for the last 40 years to say now
in April of 2020 Bernie has become
disingenuous doesn't make sense we
got six and a half months to fight Trump
until we either get four more years of
it or we get something better
Bernie's keeping his eye on the ball
that's a good thing
you would think that the trust he has
built with his supporters would have
them saying you know Bernie's probably
right
rather than Bernie has sold out to the
DNC which you don't believe he's done
for 40 years why would he do it now
let's think critically guys I've got
something really cool today the first
500 people who see this video and go to
david pakman.com slash skill will get a
premium membership to Skillshare for two
months for free skill shares the online
learning community offering thousands of
classes on almost anything you can
imagine
everything's taught by experts the
classes get split up into bite-size
lessons so even if you're really busy
like me you can fit Skillshare into your
schedule there are classes on drawing
painting photography video editing web
design running a small business and
that's not even scratching the surface I
got some great ideas from a recent class
I took called YouTube success and even
though we've been on YouTube for years I
still got a lot out of it they have
classes for every skill level whether
you want to get better at something
you're already experienced in or you
want to explore something totally new
and like I said the first 500 people who
see this video and go to david
pakman.com slash skill will get a
completely free premium membership for
two months giving you access to every
class Skillshare offers check it out I
put the link right underneath this video